Japan has some of the longest working hours in the world.
Nearly a quarter of Japanese companies...
...have their employees work more than 80 hours of overtime per month.
Those extra hours are often unpaid.
Today, Japan's corporate culture is driven by the so-called "salaryman".
The salaryman is defined by his loyalty to his company...
...and expected to spend his entire career working for the same firm.
The nation's work ethic dates back...
...to what's referred to as Japan's Economic Miracle,...
...which was its dramatic economic growth beginning in the 1950s,...
...which propelled it to become the world's second-largest economy.
Inside Japan's corporations,...
...the culture emphasizes the success of a company as a whole...
...to be more important than any single individual,...
...which might explain why one study found...
...that 63% of Japanese felt guilty for taking paid leave.
Japan's government has considered several initiatives...
...to curb the number of hours spent at the office,...
...including making it mandatory to take at least five vacation days a year...
...and requiring a rest period between the end of one day and the start of another.